[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là
quand on peut faire le beau gosse moi je
vous le dit aussi je vous donne des
petites techniques pour vous qui vous
regardez avec les meufs jamais de dire
qu on a froid jamais dire qu'on dort à
giuly jamais dire qu'on n'a jamais dire
qu'on va aux toilettes jamais dire qu'on
va chez le coiffeur jamais dire voilà
pourquoi je vous dis enfin confort il ya
plein d'interdît en fait à bien sûr
kaeppelin d'interdît regarder et lui il
a tout dit il restait à bagram qui
seront avec nous un instant on fera un
détecteur de menton
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé je vais vers la corse de la
promo bat pas avec des livres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite la question corps la
question
[Musique]
à
la question qu aucune
[Musique]
ça
nous sentons
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois jeunes restaient pas de maire dans
son émission a l'air en forme
[Applaudissements]
voilà
là
à chaque fois vous allez haute états
unis moi je moi j'étais avec une une
américaine un moment à chaque fois que
je faisais quelque chose à me dire
donnez là bas jouer brosser les dents
rôle arrivé dans l'anonymat fait ch
occupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous racontais parce que c'est
vraiment un truc de ouf je suis
tranquillement je suis allé chercher mes
enfants à l'école et j'étais avec mon
ami youssef on arrive et on rentre à la
maison
six ou sept qui conduisait on avec les
enfants derrière et là youssef
comme il est très fine et on ne peut pas
faire un créneau il rentre comme ça
l'américaine c'est-à-dire qu'il est un
créneau à la fois chez moi mes frères
voilà voilà la tunisienne pendant qu'il
rêve en direct et sur moi il y avait une
mini austin était garé là une mini mes
frères il a défoncé la voiture elle est
priée vous faire et les enfants
dérangeaient discret mon père les
enfants qui crient dans la voiture mais
c'est la défense elle a bon dos là je
reçois un sms
frérot tu as voulu tuer ma femme quoi
mme arthur
non c'était la peau comme par hasard on
lui a défoncé sacrément tu n'écoutes
fait les réparations et on se parlera
donc 5 6 7 6 le grand patron du groupe
canal veut que je reste bien entendu je
resterai puisque il est hors de question
que je leur fasse un coup dans le dos et
veut nous ont donné notre chaîne note
science sur ses huit précédents
j'en ai fait des radios quand vous
faites les rues de matha pour les
chiffres tombent il vous trouve toujours
un truc que vous êtes produire un jour
les messes basses à 16h on est con
cartonne sur nenê qui trouve toujours là
en radio frère tu auras toujours un mec
à te dire on est premier sur les mecs
qui manque des salsifis avec
10 exclu sur le coup de foudre entre
nicolas sarkozy et carla bruni
vous aimez nommé mots je vous dis
pourquoi je vous aime on va pas se
mentir
nous nous montrons pas mais entre amis
ici margot robbie je vous le dis je vous
le redis margot robbie s'avance puisque
apparemment c'est moi qui vais aller la
voir à londres un nouveau dit oui je
suis en train d'organiser et peut-être
qu'on entendrait organisé entre nos deux
attachées de presse
une rencontre à londres london to be in
an interview en anglais bien sûr suivi
d'un coup bien sûr j'ai appelé la wall
street institute spectacle s'appelle où
des rixes bac ce matin 12h10
on s'est dit on va jouer avec des packs
celui qui gagnent
on verra un pack d'eau à la gueule ou
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
j'adore les cheveux mouillés un ouais
ouais c'est vrai que alors dubai
je sors de l'eau fait pour vous et télé
chérie je sors de l'eau comme ça on
dirait que naldo mouvante et les genres
sont comme des oufs roi
[Musique]